How do we reopen American society in a way that keeps people safe
but also puts them back to work and school?
One of the most realistic and workable plans comes from a team of policy analysts
led by Avik Roy, the president of the Austin, Texas-based Foundation for Research on Equal Opportunity.
Even without widespread testing, a vaccine, or a cure, they argue that we should reopen schools
and allow healthy younger workers to go
back to work because COVID-19 kills mostly
older people with pre-existing health problems who can be protected without shutting everything down.
Roy argues that the massive expansion of government creates a further drag on the economy
that is mostly invisible to DC bureaucrats and commentators. The more we lock down the economy,
the more we harm those individuals who are most vulnerable, who don't have the cash cushions
or the white-collar jobs that allow them to keep going he says. Even as he is hopeful that in many regulations
that have been suspended during the pandemic will never return.
Avik thanks for talking to Reason. Hey Nick it's always a pleasure to be with you.
How are you? You know doing as well as I can you
are in Austin Texas right I am yep yeah
okay and I'm in New York so you know
it's weird New York is the epicenter in
America Texas has been doing pretty well
so far
yes let's uh you know talk about your
plan why is it imperative that we open
the economy as quickly as possible well
I mean every single one of your
listeners or viewers knows how much
economic destruction has been wronged by
the lockdowns you know everything is
going out of state local federal level
it's been incredible as of the time that
we're recording this video there have
been 22 million new unemployment filings
by Americans the impact on economic
output could be even greater than that
it's pretty much a catastrophe we're at
basically depression level economic
activity now you might say well all
that's worth it because we're we're
stopping kovin 19 right well that's
the heart of the paper the heart of the
paper is that maybe we could use a more
targeted effort to to get the economy
back on line without this blunt-force
instrument of locking down everything
and also by the way we kind of need to
because the the core idea in our paper
is that you know we've been told and
there been all these other papers as
well you know we just have to keep the
economy a lock down for a bit here and
once we get the testing going and we get
a treatment developed for over nineteen
and we we've we've developed more
immunity as a community and and we've
developed a vaccine and we're on our way
to develop a vaccine then it'll be fine
and we can all you know unlock the
common everything go back to normal the
problem is there's a very good chance
that we could fail at each one of those
steps let alone all of them at the same
time and any one of those steps I should
say that relative all in the same time
and so what happens if we don't get
testing ramped up fast enough what
happens if we don't develop a treatment
that works in in the next couple of
months maybe it takes six months maybe
takes 12 months to develop an effective
treatment what then
are we gonna keep the economy shut down
for twelve months and our answer is no
we cannot write the economy shut down
for 12 months and therefore we have to
think about everything we can do to get
the economy going again so let's let's
uh dilate a little bit on the economic
kind of havoc that's been wrought so far
in your paper you talked about basically
in the month of lock down the first
month of lock down GDP or economic
activity declined by about thirty
percent
you mentioned 22 million unemployment
filings in the expansion that took place
over the past decade there were 23
million jobs created so we're almost
back to where we were
circa about 2010 what are the costs you
know part of part of what's going on so
far is that the discussion and
understandably so has been mostly
focused on the health outcomes you know
people are dying we want to stop people
from dying what are the health outcomes
that are related to you know a depleted
or a decimated economic sector well
there is actually a lot of academic
research on the topic of what happens
when you have higher on
point write rates for example that
there's an increase in mortality due to
higher unemployment now there are some
conflicting you know countervailing
arguments that like or evidence such as
you know if you really shut down the
economy yes you in and of itself you
might have higher unemployment due to
deaths of despair and things like that
but because nobody is driving or fewer
people a driver maybe if you were
traffic yeah I mean it's it's very
complicated to do a true even if a fake
true cost-benefit analysis but but it
deserves to be but there is a cost and I
would say more importantly than the the
cost in terms of fatalities is the human
cost of keeping people out of work right
we all know and there's a mounting
evidence of the value of work and
gainful employment apart from you know
just you know a deaths and and things
like that so there's a lot of there's a
normos human cousin by the way you know
let's not forget that there is also a
cost to the massive expansion of
government that then creates a further
drag on the economy think of the fiscal
drag that's caused by the massive
increase in the federal debt just in the
past couple of months the the further
pressure on to raise taxes that will
come up as a result of that and the
acceleration of the potential fiscal
crisis that comes from the point at
which people basically decide that
america's broke and stop buying Treasury
bonds there's a lot of downstream
effects from what we're doing right now
that are incredibly costly and every
month that goes by this is the key thing
every month that goes by that we
continue to shut down the economy means
we have to do more of this massive you
know shovel out the door trillions of
dollars kind of relief and so that the
timing is of the essence we have we do
not have time to sit here and wait for a
months and months and months do you
think that that's you know your group is
the foundation for research on equal
opportunity I mean your focus and I
think this is you know a kind of
wonderful mission that you put for
yourselves to talk about how do you how
do you take the
people in the lower-income you know
whatever you want to call it quartile
quintile you know decile whatever and
how do you give them more opportunity
about 37% there's a study that came out
recently from University of Chicago
Booth Business School saying that if you
stretch it maybe thirty seven percent of
the workforce can work from home
full-time you know that includes most
reporters a lot of a lot of health care
/ not health care professionals who are
working in hospitals but people who
commentate on all of this stuff do you
think we're in a lot of ways the media
and the chattering classes are kind of
soft selling the difficulty that this is
putting on people because we don't work
from them I mean I've been working from
home basically for almost 25 years now
this is bad for me but it is not a you
know it's not a degree in magnitude or
it's it's only a degree in difference
not in kind of what it was before the
lockdown
you know it's it's funny Nick I've been
thinking about this a lot because we put
out our plan at the time that we're
recording is we put out our plan a week
prior we put it actually on a revised
version today with a lot of new evidence
and recommendations but the point in the
week that in the week that the plans
been out since we've recorded we're
recording this I've been struck by the
number of interviews I've done with
people based in Washington who said well
don't you think it's pointless to try to
restart the economy because everyone
will want to stay home and look I I
certainly do agree that there are going
to be people who are risk averse and
people who want to stay home but DC is a
peculiar place in terms of the
prevalence of that attitude and I think
it comes down to two things that's one
is what you described which is 37% of
Americans have the luxury of being able
to work from home with minimal
interruption to their employment
two-thirds of the country cannot that's
a factor number one but factor number
two which is arguably just as important
is that the Washington Politico media
ecosystem prospers independently of the
functioning of the real economy so if
you compare DC white-collar workers to
say New York City white-collar workers
or Silicon Valley white-collar workers
yes all those white-collar workers can
work from home but if you ask anyone in
the investment world are they happy that
the economy is tanking they're not if
you ask anyone in Silicon Valley whose
businesses depend on a robust
advertising and business climate they're
not happy they're yes they can work from
home but the value of their businesses
is getting crushed because business has
gone to a standstill so I think those
other white-collar communities in which
there's much more of an awareness of the
economic damage and how it affects them
directly I think they're much more eager
to get this show on the road
you know before we go to these specific
recommendations that your plan lays out
let's also talk a little bit about the
idea of testing and tracking or tracing
or whatever one of the things that is
interesting and I think different about
your plan than some others that have
come at is that you're you're kind of
assuming the worst that we're not going
to have for a bus testing and and you
know clearly between what was promised
to us by you know both federal
government as well as state and local
governments we're not seeing that kind
of testing talk about we're testing is
falling down and why it's actually
pretty unlikely that we're going to be
doing you know millions of tests a day
on a repeating or a revolving basis well
for anyone who really wants a more
technical description of why testing is
going to be hard to ramp up I encourage
you to read the paper at free or but to
boil it down for your your audience here
what it comes down to is that there are
two kinds of tests broadly speaking
they're antibody based tests and there
are viral RNA based tests that actually
look at the amount of viral RNA in your
body the antibody based tests have
several advantages of several
disadvantage the advantages are they're
quick and they're easy to use you can
even use them from home in certain cases
the disadvantage is their accuracy is a
lot lower and also what antibodies arise
after you've had infections you can go a
couple weeks after you've been infected
and not yet have antibodies the
antibodies really start to pop up after
the virus has been in your system for a
couple of weeks so an animal adabot a
negative test isn't
proof that you aren't infected and an
antibody positive test isn't proof that
you're immune to future infections it
may be that you've generated antibodies
but they don't actually help your immune
system fight off a future infection we
just don't know right now now the DNA
tests the RNA test excuse me the what
are called PCR tests for polymerase
chain reaction those tests are much more
accurate at detecting whether the virus
is present in your system the problem is
those tests are much more cumbersome
because you know detecting DNA or RNA in
your body is just requires a lot more
sensitivity it requires healthcare
professionals to administer the test and
and and do the testing so it can only be
done really in clinics and labs and
hospitals and places like that so
there's just a bottleneck there in terms
of there's only so many healthcare
facilities we have to administer the
rt-pcr test so as a result we're faced
with one choice test that can scale up
in theory but are inaccurate and tests
that are really accurate but are very
cumbersome to administer and hard to
scale on so so we're kinda let me say
that we it's gonna take us a while to
scale up the testing a long time it
could be six months right and so I mean
we're kind of early on if we want to do
anything before that we're gonna be kind
of flying blind in terms of you know do
we know what percentage of the
population or what individuals are
infected or not your basic you know so I
mean basically what you're saying in
your plan is we need to open the economy
as quickly as possible and we're gonna
be doing that with we're gonna be kind
of flying without instruments in a very
foggy like nighttime scenario you do say
we should be using quarantines and
contact tracing as things open up but
what is the meat of what are the actions
that need to be taken do you think to
open up the economy or open up society
more broadly as safely as possible well
before we get to that I do want to say
we're not flying totally blind at this
point Nick we do have a reasonable
amount of evidence to help us
characterize what's actually going on
with koban 19 first of all there have
been a handful of a community-wide
antibiotic testing program so for
example very recently Santa Clara
County and Silicon Valley did they
surveyed I think was three thousand or
six thousand people in their community
with a demographically representative
sample to see how many people were
infected and it turned out that there
are about 60 times 6-0 60 times as many
people infected with Coppa 19 based on
antibody testing as people who actually
had symptoms of any sort of disease or
illness related to Cova 19 which which
gives us a great deal of confidence that
the risk of infection the person that
you'll be hospitalized or died because
you've been infected is actually much
lower than then the worst case in errors
and have indicated the other thing we
know about koba 19 is that it
disproportionately affects the elderly
if you're over 85 you have an over 1,000
fold likelihood of dying from Coe by 19
than if you're under 35 so the young are
very low at risk for hospitalization
death and the elderly are much higher at
risk for hospitalization and so those
two things and also by the way if you're
sort of middle-aged like you and I are
Nick then if you're if you have diabetes
or you have other chronic diseases that
can make you more susceptible to risk
for Kovan I know some stuff yeah and and
and that you know if you're safe 50 and
older and you don't have underlying
conditions you're looking at a couple
percentage points two or three percent
of being hospitalized lower than that of
dying from the disease so part of your
pitch is that the younger you are the
more freedom you should have to reenter
the economy can you talk a little bit
about that and and what what concrete
steps would change if we reopen
according to your plan all right so
that's those are the key things so it's
because we're not flying completely
blind because we do have some evidence
as to the relative risk of different
populations that does does give us some
opportunity to reopen parts of the
economy strategically so this is what
our plan is not some just open the
floodgates and let everything happen
come what may
it's more it's more careful than that so
the idea is first let's
open the schools K through 12 and pre-k
because the youngest people in our in
our country are the lowest at risk for
hospitalization and death and getting
people into schools has two effects one
it helps kids get educated 2 it also
helps the parents of those kiddos kids
go to work because right now there are a
lot of parents who can't work because
they have to take care of their kids
every day so that's a huge opportunity
now we do care we do take care to say
look if you are a child who lives with
your grandparents or other at-risk
individuals maybe it's best that you
continue to stay at home and for those
individuals we got to do more with
virtual learning and other online
technologies to help those individuals
keep what about what about teachers you
know because teachers tend to be you
know I'm assuming that most teachers are
somewhere between about 35 and 65 but do
you screen for them or do you allow them
you know in the more robust version of
this would you allow them to decide
whether or not they want to put
themselves you know around people who
may be asymptomatic but carriers of the
disease in the plan we recommend that
older teachers and staff stay home and
don't return to schools but you know
ultimately because schools are run at
the local level you know localities will
be able to experiment with a wide
variety of approaches in terms about
adilyn maybe you really focus on testing
or maybe you leave it up to the teachers
say hey here are the risks sign a
disclosure form saying or a consent form
saying you understand the risks and then
if you want to continue working that's
up to you because there may be some
people who feel that was like I don't
care if I'm 70 I still want to teach my
kids so let them have the choice right
so maximize that that latitude and you
also talk you know you said like let
people sign waivers saying you know that
they give informed consent essentially
to say I might be you know exposed to
Cova 19 you talk in the plan about
changing relaxing the legal liability
for states as well as for employers can
you discuss that a little bit more yeah
so one thing we talked about in the plan
is is so the part of the plan that's
about having people re-enter the
workforce leaving aside the schools
getting younger people in particular in
the workforce remember one things that's
so weird about our situation now from a
policy standpoint is the
these disproportionately affects people
who are over 65 the workforce is
disproportionately under 65 and yet
those are the people were locking out of
the economy right so we've got to do
everything we can to get younger people
back into the workforce and one way we
can accelerate that not just for the
youngest and the healthiest people is to
offer a tax credit to employers who
offer tests to their koba 19 tests to
their to their employees that not not
only would that do a lot to bring more
people back to work but for restaurants
and retail shops and other places it
could help those the consumer feel
confident that that restaurant or that
shop is is Co bid free so it could have
two effects and so employers can do that
but the one that the challenges are we
have all these regulations right now
about the ability of employers to do
this kind of thing because if you're an
employer and you administer a test like
that to your worker and you know the
result of that test there are certain
privacy regulations in place that you'd
have to sort of at least create some
kind of safe harbor around and also
liability around you know how safe our
bure are the liability around how those
tests are deployed
well the way or is maybe reluctant to do
it right but but then you also do create
a kind of market in you know as you were
suggesting just as a restaurant has a
letter grade or something from a food
inspection we would say you know we test
our employees for kovat blah blah blah
and that that would help make that
restaurant seem more acceptable to
customers why why attacks a set of
rather than a Direct Subsidy I mean we
just passed a 2.2 trillion dollar
bailout it's the beginning of multiple
more bailouts to come clearly before the
end of the fiscal year what why not just
a straight subsidy you could do it as a
direct subsidy I mean from an economic
standpoint the effective tax credit
that's you know versus a subsidy are
pretty similar so from my standpoint
it's it's not that important whether
it's a direct subsidy or a tax incentive
if you if you administer a test today in
theory it's deductible from your taxes
so the concept here is that this would
be something on top of the deductibility
of the expense for for a business
so however you want to do it is fine by
me you know I'm agnostic on that now you
you still talk about in the in the paper
that certain types of gatherings would
be prohibited talk about you know you
you're basically willing to reopen all
aspects of the economy subject to the
provisos that you had before but then
there are certain types of you know
types of I guess workplace or businesses
like nightclubs and whatnot or bar as
they say no this is this is a no-go area
talk about the restrictions in your plan
and then how do we know when things have
passed enough so that we can say okay
yes to nightclubs again the I think the
way I'd put it Nick is we have to go
from a mentality the mentality we've had
for the first month of this lockdown is
how do we get everyone to shut
everything down if you're a governor
you're like how do you convince people
to stay off the beaches and stay out of
the restaurants and stop talking hanging
out with other people and going on dates
or whatever right so that's been the
mentality up to this point and what
we're trying to do with this plan is
change the mentality to want to where
we're thinking every day about what
section of the economy we can reopen
what section of the population can we
liberate from these restrictions and so
while our plan does accept that some
restrictions will need to continue in
the riskiest types of activities like
big gatherings indoors for example our
our goal is to say let's take the lowest
risk types of activities and reopen
those so that means anything that you
can do safely you know taking into
account things like social distance so
when you open a restaurant let's try to
make sure that the restaurant opens up
with maybe fewer tables in it in its
floor plan and things like that which
means of course the restaurant will not
make as much money as it did before but
at least it's something right so our
goal here our mentality with all this
stuff is to say how can we open up that
part of the economy as soon as possible
without jeopardizing public health and
and our our goal is also by the way as
evidence comes in right we're still very
early in the evidence gathering stage
here like you were talking about before
so it may be that over time we learn
that certain categories of people that
we thought were risky we're not or
certain types of activities that we
thought were risky or not and the
more of that evidence piles up the more
we can can o reopen the economy with
broad public support and broad political
support across the ideological camps
what is yours
well before we get to a broader question
so let me ask you one other thing which
I think would particularly or
conceivably raise libertarian hackles
you say that you would require negative
tests for kovat 19 for passengers on air
an Amtrak Amtrak is minimal you know the
number of people who actually travel on
Amtrak even in the Acela corridor it's
small but it's a federal system but why
for air passengers why would you say you
got to have a negative test for that
well it's a great question I mean at the
end of the day I think you're just gonna
have a lot of people who are not gonna
want to fly if they think they're gonna
be stuck in a metal tube for five hours
or three hours or whatever it is with
people who are infected with stars polka
- so you've got to restore confidence
somehow it's gonna be difficult because
they're about 2.7 million people who fly
on planes a day in the precoded world in
the u.s. so how do you get that how do
you get testing up to a scale where you
can you know ramp it up like that it's
gonna be hard but at the end of the day
our economy cannot go back to what it
was if travel is effectively shut down
like it is today so it's just like with
what we were discussing before you know
it's not that we like these restrictions
at all it's not like that that we're
trying to create a nanny state it's
quite the opposite at the end of the day
the way we look at this whole this whole
problem is that we've got to lift as
many of these restrictions as possible
in a way that is aware of the public
health risks and and and strategic about
that because at the end of the day if we
have another spike in kovat infections
then there's going to be an award is not
in anybody's interest right so if we
want to have the freest possible economy
in the in this environment we've got to
get you know move up move the ball down
the field in a more gradual way do you
know Ronald Reagan was famous for saying
that there is nothing so permanent as a
temporary gum
program I think when we talk about you
know spending issues but especially with
the civil liberties or the idea that
governments at all levels but especially
you know the bigger the level or you
know the the higher up the bigger the
impact is how do we make sure that some
of the restrictions on you know on
mobility on movement but especially on
things like having to test or
you know showing that you you know kind
of an internal passport system on less
where I've done this so I can do this
how do you make sure that those are
limited only to a crisis period well I
think what's what's really what I hope
will happen first of all is that the the
evidence as it accumulates and rolls in
will show that COBIT nineteen is far
less dangerous than some of the PhDs out
there with their models thought there
was there was enormous deference to a
very very small number of people who
were projecting disaster scenarios I
mean two million people one the CDC's
original doomsday scenarios 1.7 million
Americans dying now the accepted figure
which may be revised downward is more
like sixty thousand which is awful but
is a long ways from 1.7 or two million
people yeah I mean 60,000 is a normal
influenza year in the United States and
look some people will argue well you
can't compare the two because the 60,000
is the result of all these interventions
right I don't think we can be sure that
maybe they're the result of these
interventions maybe they were the result
of some interventions but not all of
them maybe they're not the result of
these interventions if you look at a
country like Sweden where there's been a
much more modest policy response the
pattern of the infection has been pretty
similar to everywhere else so how and
even within you know this is something
that I think will be will be I hope
we'll be discussing for a long time to
come when you look at states you know a
state like Florida which was very late
to lock down and got you know the
governor there get a lot of grief for
letting Spring Breakers come there
infection rate is better than a lot of
states I'd locked down earlier and have
been more draconian and restrictions so
the correlation between public policy
and
the path of the disease it's not it's
not exactly clear that you know keeping
people at home that's right so it's
going to be very important for
organizations like yours and mine too to
put that pedal to the metal and make
sure that we're highlighting the policy
response and its relationship to what
actually happened at particularly as
time goes on right now obviously there's
a lot of uncertainty we don't we can't
draw firm conclusions about a lot but
but there is a mounting pile of evidence
here that the policy reaction was was an
overreaction a big part of why by the
way is because most of the policy
response is a playbook that comes from
influenza and coronavirus kovat 19 is
not influenza it disproportionately
affects the elderly in a way that
influenza influenza also has a skewed
towards the elderly but more because the
elderly are just already sick whereas
the sku here is much greater and so
there was much more of an opportunity to
take advantage of that knowledge to say
hey let's really be careful about
nursing homes let's be careful about
elderly populations but let's let people
go to school particularly younger kids
and let's like younger people behave
responsibly by the way with young people
your eye does your plan and looking
through it I saw the K through 12 stuff
what about colleges and universities
because this is I know a lot of people
in higher ed and obviously you know
there's tons of young people in higher
ed it's unclear whether or not colleges
will be reopening in the fall or you
know where if they'll be doing it kind
of in a in a partial way well listen I'm
a huge college football fan so I
personally hope that the colleges go
back it's a shame you live in Texas than
a state with the terrible college
football but so I so all that say we
didn't address it in the plan because we
felt that the college question is is
very complex as we've got very large
student bodies you've got a lot of older
faculty and staff so there it just there
was just the complexity of how to untie
that knot was a little harder I think
whereas the K through 12 in the pre-k
situation is much more high ambiguous in
terms of the in terms of the health
Public Health
Seiden I think on the one hand I'm
saying we need to make sure that any
incursion any growth of government in
terms of spending or in terms of
surveillance powers is sharply limited
to a crisis situation and it ends there
on another level I want to ask you about
you know there's been a number of
regulations and restrictions on business
on health the TSA etc where they've been
like you know what in the face of kovat
we're not going to require and this is
part of your paper you know states are
not going to require medical
professionals who are licensed in one
state to sit around and pay extra money
and cool their heels or take useless
tests to be able to practice in another
state
how do we make sure that the kind of
libertarian animus in some of this to
get rid of restrictions that we say hey
you know what this we can we do we can't
afford to have this restriction how do
we make sure that that mentality
survives the end of the pandemic and
that you know it is it is it too broad
to say if a regulation was getting in
the way of helping people stay safe
during the corona virus pandemic it
should never be brought you know it
should never see the light of day again
yeah a great question and again this is
an area where libertarians and other
pro-freedom activists have got to put
the pedal to the metal and say and hold
policy makers and politicians
accountable and say hey this is
ridiculous why do we keep why do we have
these antiquated laws on the books that
are all about gilda style protection not
about actually helping patients and
doctors do their jobs let alone nurse
practitioners and nurse and essences and
everything else I mean when I moved to
Texas from New York you know yes I had
to get a Texas driver's license but I
didn't have to do it on day one I had to
do it you know within a certain time
frame so you didn't have to take a
driving exam you just yeah I didn't
exactly I didn't have I didn't have to
stop driving for six months while I got
my driver's license right so like this
idea that somehow if you move from one
US state to another US state somehow
you're suddenly incompetent to practice
medicine is ridiculous so what's a
simple adjustment would be to say first
state to say okay the next time your
license comes up for renewal you have to
renew it in our state and not in that
other state but in the
time will honor your license so it's a
temporary thing that doesn't really
affect you and allows you to practice
immediately if you move to another state
that would be a simple reform that would
do very little to undermine state
sovereignty and licensure and yet would
create a lot more mobility and
flexibility so there are lots of things
like that that we could do yeah your
your background is in healthcare I mean
that was you you were a major voice in
arguing against what became known as
Obamacare and whatnot how do you think
this pandemic is going to affect the
healthcare industry of the medical
medical delivery sector because yeah you
know and and also can you make sense of
these competing stories you're here one
wasn't early on and I know in New York
State and New York City we were told
that hospitals were going to be
absolutely crushed by Kovac patients we
need Andrew coma at one point was saying
we need something like 40,000
ventilators they had 12,000 they are now
loaning out ventilators to other nearby
states and things like that how is this
going to affect the medical industry I
really worry about that piece of it on
multiple levels one I see a lot of small
physician practices that are getting
crushed because patients aren't coming
in and they're just like small
businesses anywhere else and so there
are a lot of small clip that doctors
practices that are there hemorrhaging
money right now the other thing I worry
about is hospitals the biggest problem
with our health care system in terms of
how expensive it is is hospitals and now
you're gonna have every single hospital
go to their local senator or congressman
and say you've got to give us more money
you've got to subsidize this more you've
got to protect us from more competition
because if you don't what happens the
next time there's a pandemic and we go
belly-up and so there's going to be an
incredible I fear an incredible
political urge to protect these dinosaur
incumbent hospitals that are parasites
on the economy and some of them not all
of them of course but but some of them
the way they overcharge you because
there are regional monopolies and know
they can charge you whatever they want
and take advantage of that incumbent
protection you so it's a huge problem
and and I think
I worry that the the movement that we're
very involved in to try to create more
competition more choice in how you get
your hospital care is going to be
stymied by incumbents in this in this
era you know it's almost kind of quaint
to remember that we're in the middle of
a presidential election year and that
before Bernie Sanders bowed out he was a
very strong proponent of single-payer
health care you know Republicans often
talk a good game about wanting to bring
the free market into health care but
they all law Medicare which is the
single-payer system one of the weird
outcomes of this kind of pandemic and
internationally is that single-payer
systems or non single-payer systems you
know it's hard to say ok did one perform
better or not what is your sense first
off of how health care is financed how
has that affected different nations
responses and then secondly politically
within the u.s. do you think this is
going to push people towards embracing
single-payer health care or not or is it
just a non-issue as far as that
particular topic goes
that's a great question Nick and we
actually are in the process of free up
of rolling out a major study of
international comparison of
international healthcare systems where
we don't directly talk about kovat 19
because it's just too new of a situation
but we do talk a lot about international
healthcare system and just like you said
there's no real correlation between the
kind of health care system you have from
an insurance standpoint and how your
country performed so Italy is a
single-payer system they obviously have
borne the brunt of this on the other
hand so is Taiwan and they've done okay
right similarly Singapore's done
reasonably well they're much more
consumer driven system Switzerland has
done all right their consumer driven
system the u.s. is sort of half-and-half
we're doing sort of in the middle I'd
say what really seems to have correlated
success in dealing with this pandemic is
not single payer versus market-based
healthcare it has been more if you were
one of the countries that dealt with
SARS the original SARS in 2003 which is
the Pacific Rim countries if you're
Taiwan or South Korea or Singapore
and you have that muscle memory of what
it was like to deal with SARS which was
just as terrifying for them as Koba 19
is for us that meant that when when the
stories started coming out of Wuhan they
took it a lot more seriously than the
rest of the world did and went swung
right into action with a lot of the
tools they developed from that
experience with SARS in 2003 so my hope
is that we will have something some of
you look at those countries today
writing precoded 19 legal those
countries today their economies are
reasonably free if you look at the
Heritage index of the world you know
economic freedom or the phrase ERISA to
do whichever one you like you know the
the hong kong's and the and the
singapore is do pretty well on those
criteria and South Korea as well so and
Taiwan so those are relatively free
countries and they stayed relatively
free despite SARS the experience of SARS
so my hope is that we should not see
this crisis as an excuse for a permanent
decrement in our economic freedom we
should in fact use it as an opportunity
by first of all making sure that these
temporary policy measures are as
temporary as possible but also to the
point you made earlier making sure that
where we're pointing out how
deregulation not just a say telemedicine
or license you know you know license
licensure but things like the fact that
we depended on a single CDC lab to
develop the test for Kovan 19 in a way
that really harmed our ability to
respond to the situation that the FDA
went out of its way to stop people from
developing their own homemade tests
early on in this crisis when it could
have really helped there are a lot of
things to re-examine and again there's
going to be a lot of opportunity I hope
for people like you and me and others to
do that you you mentioned it in passing
the idea you know we have something like
23 trillion dollars in in national debt
right now and and that's probably I mean
we're probably going to spend another
two trillion dollars before the end of
the fiscal year I'd you know I think
that's a safe that maybe even
conservative almost doubling the federal
budget for 2020 and in the pew know in
the span of a couple months what is the
is there a predictable effect of first
off of having a mass
of national debt like this on economic
growth and prosperity and then what
happens when you top that off I mean you
know with I I don't even know what the
metaphor is but where you might be
adding you know a couple of trillion
dollars of debt in a in a in a couple we
already did and a couple month period
what does that do in the short term in
the mid term and in the long term do you
think to economic activity well in the
short term it's unclear right I mean I
think that the biggest impact on
economic activity is just a lock down
and getting people comfortable with
resuming something resembling a normal
life
in the mid to long term the picture is
bleak in terms of the impact of the
fiscal stuff we don't know exactly when
the reckoning will happen but we do know
that and there was a study done in the
last recession the Rogoff and Reinhart
program yesterday where they said if you
if you if your debt to GDP ratio exceeds
I think ninety percent then the impact
on economic growth the dragon on the
nama growth is considerable and there's
no larger country that can bail out the
United States if we we become insolvent
you know we're stuck and by the way
before this crisis we were looking at a
situation where within a decade we're
gonna be spending more on interest on
the federal debt than we were spending
on national defense that's how big a
problem is so you know what happens to
Bitcoin in this environment obviously
Bitcoin price has been volatile and they
in 2020 but could we see a situation
where if people lack confidence in the
credit of the United States the Full
Faith and Credit United States that we
move to alternative assets like golden
and cryptocurrency as a store of value I
think that's something that may very
well happen as things shake out and if
that happens then the u.s. is ability to
borrow money to finance that debt will
start to decline and become more
expensive and that could lead to a
spiraling in terms of the the fiscal and
financial and economic crisis so this is
a very serious problem and I really I
there's there's no precedent for it in
terms of our politicians being able to
reduce the deficit and debt so you know
good luck to us all yeah I mean oh you
know though I mean
annal it's not even an analogue it's
just kind of a premonition I guess after
World War two
there had been massive spending both
because of the New Deal but especially
World War two and then the federal
government really cut spending
particularly on defense but on a lot of
other things and deregulated the economy
very quickly and there was a burst of
activity it doesn't seem like that
political economy makes sense anymore
you know when the when the recession
ended the bailouts didn't end
government spending didn't end really so
that's going to be quite challenging
could you also before you move on from
that let me just say there's a couple of
important differences between the world
war two time and now and the different
the key is the most important difference
is that we have Medicare and Medicaid we
have these giant health care
entitlements built off of social
security in a way that are on autopilot
so World War two spending was subject to
congressional appropriations in fiscal
wonky terms it was discretionary money
every year Congress decides how much are
we gonna spend on this versus that the
Medicare and Medicaid are not like that
they're on autopilot Congress actually
has to pass laws that they want to
restrain spending on Medicare and
Medicaid and that's you know half the
budget right now so we problem is that
whew yeah so that's that's the real
challenge is that the structure of the
way we spend money is completely
different than it wasn't World War two
if you look at discretionary spending
it's actually reasonably low as a
percentage of our economy by historical
standards
it's that mandatory health care
entitlement spending that's out of
control I think you know a good starting
point would be to end the use of
mandatory and discretionary as budget
terms because none of it is mandatory
all of it is discretionary but and and I
know even when I started writing about
the federal budget in the early 2000s
really with you know with regularity it
used to be you know that the starting
point of every budget discussion is that
50 percent was in the discretionary you
know pile and 50 percent was in
mandatory and it's no longer the case
it's more like 2/3 is mandatory and it's
ramping up quicker and quicker how how
does a kind of diminished or a flatline
economy affect you know people in the
bottom half
the bottom third of the income
distribution and-and-and of the
opportunity to get because again your
organization is about trying to create
more opportunities for people who have
you know fewer economic prospects your
educational process prospects you know
what what can be done particularly to
help ignite that part of the economy so
that you know because this is partly I
think about am i I have two sons who
were millennial and a Jen's II and like
you know for the first time I'm not
jealous of them anymore because they are
they're kind of being launched into a
world that has been riven by economic
you know geopolitical and economic
catastrophe for a long time and that
doesn't seem to be changing but what do
we do you know they're in good shape I
mean they're coming from means and
options and all of that but what do you
do for people in the bottom third of the
economy when you look at the landscape
that we're going to be navigating from
the next several years well just just to
hammer home that point so at my
organization the foundation for research
on equal opportunity we have a rule that
every white paper we publish every
scholar we hire has two centers work as
arguments is policy reform ideas around
how a particular idea will help improve
the lives of Americans whose wealth or
income is below the US median and why do
we do that because at the end of the day
those of us who believe in free
enterprise know that it's free markets
that have lifted people out of poverty
it's been the greatest contribution to
material prosperity around the world but
it's up to people like us to actually
demonstrate that and do the research
that shows that and come up with the
reforms that will achieve that and so
that's what free op is centered around
so when it comes to this particular
situation that's been why we've argued
so passionately about the importance of
reopening the economy reopening the
economy doesn't matter for you know a
columnist at the Washington Post whose
job prospects are probably going to be
about the same but for that everyday
American who works at a factory it's
their life it's their entire income it's
their entire economic possibility comes
from that job or being able to send
their kids to school and
the more we lock down the economy the
more we harm those individuals who are
most vulnerable in our economy who don't
have the cash cushions or they
white-collar jobs that allow them to
keep going and by the way you know one
of the things that when we put out our
plan one of the the questions we got was
well you're arguing for a partial
reopening of the economy or you're
advocating reopening the economy for
healthy people younger people etc well
lower-income communities a minority
communities particularly African
Americans have on average poorer health
status than say upper middle class white
so aren't you in a sense creating more
racial discrimination disparities if you
if you adopt this approach and my answer
that is in the short term there may be
some disparities in that sense but the
disparities that's even worse is the
fact that if you shut down the economy
completely poor people suffer the most
and so at the end of the day if we want
low-income people to do better we have
to have economic growth and we cannot
have economic growth if everybody is
poor do you think you know this is a
dark joke but early on when it became
clear that this covered 19 was mostly
killing older people it was called the
boomer remover we're at the twilight of
the baby boom generation being you know
in the spotlight culturally politically
economically do you think this is going
to speed along a kind of generational
rift or a shift from older Americans
people you know who were born I don't
know you know before 1964 is last year
in the baby boom but to to those after
and if so will that you know is that a
positive thing in a strange way so you
know what's crazy you were talking about
the presidential election earlier Joe
Biden is actually too old to be a baby
boomer he's actually a member of the
older generation the Cylons know which
is crazy to think about it's like you
know if you're if you're Gen X you're
like come on what is it our turn
unfortunately for Gen X I think you know
it may be skipped over like Prince
Charles right
you know so that's a pretty crazy
situation and you know it is what it is
but look I mean it's hard Neil how if
you're interested in generational
writing about generational cultural
issues Neil how is the smartest guy I
know on the stuff he writes for me at
Forbes he's terrific
I in general they're there aren't these
kind of there isn't a generational war
in the sense of Millennials hating
boomers and even though there's this is
a meme on Twitter because people have
grandparents and they have relatives and
they have people they care about so I
think we're in general we may have
different mores and different outlooks
but in general we want all of we want
our parents and our and our grandparents
to succeed where I think you really see
the generational divide is more in the
future of our politics and this goes
back to live free optics is the reason
why we built free up is because we have
been an are deeply concerned that the
modern conservative movement in the
modern a pro Liberty movement is not
adapted to the way in which younger
people think about economic freedom that
is to say that you know there's this
concern out there that all the young
kids are socialists and all this kind of
stuff that's not what we see we see
Millennials Gen Z as people who really
believe in technology believe in
innovation believe in entrepreneurship
but they have no patience for the
nostalgia for 1950s America in which a
lot of black people couldn't vote and
and so that's that's the thing that's
different from them versus people and
say Joe Biden's generation and so what I
hope will happen is as we as we move to
a world in which younger people are more
in charge we stop having the the
cultural debates that we were having in
the 50s and 60s and instead oh and in
those days and mm I mean yeah yeah and
and we moved to a system where or a
country where we're not having those
kinds of arguments as much but were are
being much more about economic policy
and I think of when we do that the
pro-freedom side has a lot to commend to
it well we're going to leave it there
I've been talking with over crows the
head
free op dot-org the foundation for
research on equal opportunity if you go
to their website you can read their
paper which has already been revised
once the new strategy for bringing
people back to work during kovat 19 avec
thanks for talking thanks Nick